hey youtubers is charlie so I haven't
done a whole bunch of Wonder Woman
videos yet so I wanted to talk a little
bit about her comic book history and
some of the changes that they're making
to the DC universe based on what
happened during Batman V Superman I know
there's a conversation going on about
how their reshooting some of Suicide
Squad to make it funnier to put more
jokes in it but that's totally normal
every film does that even on smaller
films they always build in time to do
reshoots just because maybe they don't
have a complete script when they start
shooting for they sit down to edit the
film and they find that there's just
some stuff that's missing that they
didn't know about when they were
actually filming it so Suicide Squad
reshoots totally normal thing and it was
already going to be a really funny movie
the tone of Wonder Woman will be a
little bit different it'll be its
distinct own thing but that's taking
place during World War One era which is
a pretty serious time in world history
but there will be moments of humor
Wonder Woman just to bring it back
around to her was actually one of the
funniest parts of Batman V Superman and
it all comes down to the way characters
react to situations I'm gonna have to
talk a little bit about Batman V
Superman plot stuff so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the movie
I'm just got to talk about some specific
Wonder Woman moments Wonder Woman
probably has one of the funniest
reactions in the film to doomsday she's
fighting him at the end her sword is
able to pierce his skin so that's
actually something important to note for
the future but she eats a punch full-on
in the face from doomsday gets knocked
down smiles then gets back up like oh
it's on now that made me fall in love
with her so much if you felt like she
got short changed during Batman V
Superman really the Wonder Woman movie
is where she's going to become an actual
character like it's gonna tell her whole
story how she got started how she got to
the point where she decided to bail on
humanity that's all stuff that's going
to happen at the end of the Wonder Woman
film and the interesting thing is we
actually we saw this picture during
Batman V Superman I wouldn't be
surprised if we actually watch them take
that picture during the Wonder Woman
movie and in case you didn't know Wonder
Woman isn't coming out till next June
jun 23 2017 so it's still a little more
than a year away Suicide Squad is coming
August fifth at the end of this summer
so if they're doing reshoots on suicide
squad right now think about how much
more work has left to be done on Wonder
Woman so I wouldn't be surprised that
they try to do the same thing with
Wonder Woman if they like the funnier
version of soon
side squad because the DC Universe the
Zack Snyder is kind of created with
Batman V Superman is definitely darker
in tone but that doesn't mean that it
can't be funny in my mind wonder woman
is a lot closer to the tone of what you
would think a Superman film would be
like but I think it'll be a little more
subtle with his jokes than Suicide Squad
is Wonder Woman comic book history
though a lot of people are familiar with
at least one version of the character
but her origin story is a little bit
funnier than say like Superman or some
of the other big comic book characters
because of the reason she was created a
lot of comic book characters especially
Stanley characters were created to serve
a specific purpose within a story well
at the same time speaking to some larger
social issue Wonder Woman was co-created
by a psychologist to promote women's
liberation back in 1941 now being that
that was around world war 2 she also did
get tied up with some very patriotic
propaganda just like Captain America did
gotta be that Hitler but the main goal
of Wonder Woman was to become the first
really big feminist icon so a lot of her
stories featured really funny situations
where she broke free from the control of
men or literally from the bondage of men
now her backstory in the comics has been
changed a couple times over the years
most people understand it has to do with
Greek mythology but there's the Wonder
Woman that was created from a lump of
clay there's the Wonder Woman that was
born the daughter of hippolytus and Zeus
that's the most current version the new
52 version she's the actual biological
daughter of Zeus and hippolytus and I
don't know that they've actually
explained that for the Wonder Woman
movie I'm assuming that's what they're
going to go with but they haven't really
explained how the gods figure into this
DC Universe so for now we're just
thinking of her in the Amazons as
metahumans her powers in the movie
universe little bit different from her
powers in the comics I know a lot of
people are wondering why she can't fly
in the movies in the most modern
incarnation because she's born the
daughter of a god she has Hercules like
powers but she's so powerful that she
actually wears her bracelets to contain
those powers on paper though she's just
as powerful as Superman with slightly
different powers she doesn't have heat
vision but she's super strong super fast
and there's even a recent storyline
where she replaces Ares is the god of
war and her powers get jacked up even
more so I think Zack Snyder tuned her
powers way down just in the name of
diversity like they didn't want to have
to Superman fly
around looking like gods because the
whole concede a Batman V Superman is
watching the world react to this alien
God and if Wonder Woman could fly she
would look just like Superman so they
would have already gone through that by
the time Superman came along so it
wouldn't be this big thing so if you
want to blame someone for making Wonder
Woman seem less powerful than she is in
the comics just blame the writer of
Batman V Superman most of the backstory
there including in the Wonder Woman
movie is true to the original origin
story of Wonder Woman where she lives on
thin mascara Steve Trevor gets maroon
she saves him and she experiences human
society through him and that's how she
learns about the world and gets wrapped
up in this world war one plot the way
Geoff Johns has talked about the Amazons
in the Batman V Superman universe is
that before the events of the Wonder
Woman movie Amazon's were previously
meant to be protectors of the world then
got so burnt out on humanity they just
said piece were out of here we're gonna
retreat to our Island you guys can
destroy ourselves we'll see in a couple
thousand years and Wonder Woman being a
very positive hopeful character tries to
end humanity's suffering but as she
explained during Batman V Superman she
said she got tired of that a hundred
years ago so spoiler alert I guess she's
not that successful at the end of the
Wonder Woman movie maybe that means
Chris Pine ends up dying in some
horrible way in the movie we'll see it's
going to be fun but the cool thing that
Ben Affleck said about Batman at least
in the modern-day universe is that she
really does inspire him and it obviously
Superman sacrifice inspires into because
when we meet Bruce Wayne during Batman V
Superman he is at his lowest point he is
the angriest version of Batman we've
ever seen in a movie if you're looking
for a really good Wonder Woman origin
story to read you can check out the
legend of Wonder Woman it's relatively
recent and it's probably going to be the
closest to what the movie is going to go
with in terms of continuity there's also
a really good animated Wonder Woman
movie so if you don't want to read
comics you can totally watch the
animated movie that will tell her origin
story in a really interesting way but
let me know in the comments even if you
haven't read a wonder woman store in a
while what's your favorite Wonder Woman
moment of all time even though it's been
a long time since I've read it I think
my favorite Wonder Woman moment was when
she killed Maxwell Lord whenever it was
announced that he was on the Supergirl
show I was like oh man wouldn't it be
awesome if they let Supergirl break his
neck because wonder woman doesn't exist
in the TV universe
but what's gonna happen next is now that
Batman V Superman is dying down you'll
probably start hearing more about
suicide squad but it's still a long ways
off so I don't think they're going to
start dropping a whole bunch of footage
or promos for that at least until the
beginning of the summer but if there are
any videos that you guys want me to do
for Wonder Woman or the other DC films
or even Justice League just let me know
in the comments in case you guys haven't
seen it in a while you can click here to
rewatch the Wonder Woman teaser trailer
and you can click here to learn all
about fox's deadpool new mutants
spin-off movie thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight